bang bang what's going on guys hope you
guys are really excited about this
interview i really enjoyed it i think
you will as well but before we get into
that make sure that you
like this video so that more people on
youtube can find it make sure you're
subscribed to the channel
and don't forget that blockfi is the
sponsor today they've got three products
you can buy and sell crypto on their
crypto exchange you can deposit crypto
and earn up to eight point six percent
apy
in an interest bearing account or you
can deposit crypto and take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral
you can use the description right here
or you can go to blockfi.com
to learn more all right let's get in
this episode i hope you guys enjoy this
one
all right guys bang bang i've got ted
here thank you so much for doing this
sir
thank you great to be here with you pump
absolutely let's just jump into your
background before we get into the fun
stuff that you're doing with capital
allocators where'd you grow up what'd
you do
and how did you get into investing yep
grew up in the suburbs of new york the
mean streets of westchester county
uh and my father was a psychiatrist my
mother was a preschool teacher so not a
lot of business background i did have
not only a proverbial but a literal rich
uncle
a guy named jim rothenberg who passed
away a couple years ago he was the
chairman of capital group
so i had interest in stocks but i grew
up in the east coast he was west coast
and i never really had a lot of exposure
to him
and i went to college had no idea what i
was going to do
probably would have been a doctor if my
father hadn't told me just don't do that
because there's just better ways of
making a living and while i was in
school i took
a class a big seminar actually a big
lecture that dave swenson taught on
portfolio theory
class was then known as stocks for jocks
and
he mentioned that they hired one person
a year so i interviewed with the yale
investments office alongside of all the
wall street interviews this is 92 so
you're coming out of a recession i used
to
tell people the goldman sachs global
investment banking class was 18 people
that year
they were not in hiring mode and i got
the offer from yale
and decided to go really david had been
there for seven years so the portfolio
was
taking shape in his image but nobody in
the outside world
outside of a very boutique community of
money managers had any idea who he was
and what was happening
and it was fantastic so that was really
my formative education investing in that
particular style so you're really
investing in managers
learning how to find them how to do the
homework cross asset classes
and stayed for five years and ultimately
just didn't think at that point in time
i wanted to spend my whole life in new
haven and i was
lucky to get into harvard business
school and off i went thinking i'd
become
you know the next great manager that
yale employs
did that for a couple years some direct
investing both in private equity and
uh hedge funds back in uh you know 99
2000
and did not find a great home in that
for myself
and by then david had written his book
came out in 2000 and
everybody was calling me and so all of a
sudden this background that nobody
wanted to talk to me about for five
years became popular and
ended up having an opportunity to join
um at the time dan stern who who ran
reservoir capital and he wanted to build
an asset management firm he put me
together with my
my partner jeff taran who uh my late
partner
and we started protege partners back in
2002 which was a hedge fund of funds
investing in and seeding smaller hedge
funds that did that for a long time
left 2015 and a bunch of things since
then including this podcast
i i love it so we got to talk about
swenson and yale because i think that uh
there's an entire group of people who
really really understand
just what an epic run uh and what an
education you probably got there and
then there's a whole bunch of people who
listen to this podcast who
a little bit younger a little bit more
uh kind of crypto centric
probably have no clue who dave swanson
is right and have no clue what what the
importance of that is so maybe just walk
through very quickly kind of
uh who dave is the yale investment
office and then kind of what your main
learnings and takeaways were from uh
from that style of investing
yeah i would love to so david
was hired at yale to manage yale's
endowment at age
31 which was unheard of
back then before he had a phd at yale he
went to wall street
he was on the desk at he worked at
lehman brothers and solomon brothers and
he was on the desk that created the
first interest rate swap
so he's just an innovative guy a
brilliant independent thinker
and he got to yale and he looked at what
other people were doing with these pools
of capital which was mostly back then
a traditional 60 40 really u.s stocks
and bonds and
and wild diversification was not crypto
it was international stocks
and he said look yale has a really long
time horizon
and therefore they should be equity
oriented and not you know debt or credit
oriented
but just owning u.s stocks there's not a
lot of diversification in that so
let's try to find different ways of
investing that you can get equity-like
exposure and benefit from
diversification the ultimate free lunch
and um so he he did that he pursued that
people look at what he did and say oh he
likes illiquid investments but the truth
is if you own u.s stocks and bonds
anything else you do is less liquid so
he
invested in and some of this had been in
yale's portfolio it just wasn't
emphasized when he got there invested in
venture capital the investor didn't
leverage buyout funds invested in real
estate funds
all different kinds of things with this
equity orientation
and yale's returns were fantastic in
spite of that asset allocation while i
was there because the equity markets
were running it was a bull market
and in 2000 he published a book called
pioneer
pioneering portfolio management which
described
not just what he was doing but this
really elegant academic
underpinning of it all the reasons why
the data behind it how it worked and it
became a manual for other
institutional investors think endowments
foundations pension funds sovereign
wealth funds all over the world
large family offices to not only say hey
this is interesting but he gave
them the playbook so that they could go
to their committees and adopt
what's really a better approach than
just the traditional approach
um so he became very very well known for
that he's really
you know for those who don't know he's
the warren buffett of this business and
and justifiably so so what i would say
is
it wasn't just that he created this
structure
he's one of the most if not the most
brilliant investors i've ever seen
and his ability to select managers to
really understand what they're doing
across asset classes everywhere in the
world
is just extraordinary and so
he did a phenomenal job for yale and
continues to he joined yale in 1985
so he's been there 36 years
so when you think about uh what makes
him great right you say that he can go
around the world
and he can find these managers vet them
select them
and he's been able to compound money
very aggressively for an institutional
investor
uh not for a year not for five not for
ten but for literally thirty plus years
what makes him so good at doing that is
an intuition thing and just like hey
there's a once in a lifetime or once in
a generation type guy who can do that
or is it something that is a repeatable
process where other people can study it
and actually take it away and use it
themselves
yeah there's there's pieces of both so
if you start with the latter which is
what people really care about like
hey how can i do this one of the things
if you if you
look back so i worked with a bunch of
people who are terrific who later left
and became the chief investment officers
of others and other endowments and
foundations i think of andy goldin at
princeton and paula valente bowden
and donna dean recently retired from
rockefeller foundation and ellen schuman
had run the carnegie court for a long
time and seth alexander at mit
all these people were colleagues of mine
and what's interesting is that
taking the model at that time of this
multi-asset class approach with a
certain group of managers
every single one of them succeeded and
and delivered for their institutions
and that is unusual to have a group of
people coming out of the same place all
of whom do well you know by definition
some are probably quote unquote better
than others some probably are luckier
than others
but there is a structure to it and some
of the structure is the asset allocation
a big part of the structure which i'll
turn to david now is discipline
extreme discipline and asset allocation
and rebalancing strategies in having a
target for what you're looking for
and sticking to it with almost no
exceptions
and and that was something that people
can learn
um but david has a true north and he
sticks to it like nobody else
so that that's the first and probably
the most
transferable the stuff that's less
transferable
um is he understands
and embraces the risk of being different
so the asset allocation he put together
back when he did
was so different from everybody else and
i'll tell you a story it was before my
time there but
david joined in 1985 and part of what
they imposed very early on was this
concept of rebalancing
in 1987 the stock market crashed he's 33
years old
going in front of investment committee
and telling them they need to
aggressively buy equities
right after the crash to rebalance
most people don't do that and he had no
wavering in his approach to do it once
he did that
it worked which again there's always
luck involved
and imagine the credibility you got by
saying we have a set of rules we stuck
to our rules and it worked and then you
could look back
without you know with with hindsight but
without hindsight bias
and say yes this this process really
works so the the
the the individual temperament to be
able to be different
think differently put together arguments
for different and then stick to your
guns when it's not working
uh is pretty extraordinary so that's the
second you know if you start with
discipline
the second would be this this real
ability to be different and the third
is is him he is just innately talented
at assessing people and investment
strategies
uh he was one of these people that when
you're around him
every year he starts to focus on two or
three things
uh and it might be small things it might
be something has to do with terms
last year it might have had to do with
diversity he puts a letter and when he
says it he's just one of those people
that you go yep he's absolutely right
you know we're going to follow that but
he just
comes up with it himself over and over
and over again
it really sounds like the original
thinking and that independent thinking
is a critical part of this because it's
not just
hey i figured one thing out right it's
the constant almost reinvention
or looking a step ahead when you work
there i think you worked there for about
five years
uh what do you think were the biggest
things that you either one took away or
to
change the way that you invested right
so kind of after spending five years in
that environment how do you think
uh it had an impact on you yeah most of
it was the former
i mean i really it's so hard to be in a
seat like that
and think that you could do something
different that's better
because they're just so so good at it um
so most of what i learned and how i
tried to apply investing was trying to
remember
what what was it that i learned uh
everything from
you know where are you sourcing your
managers from what kinds of questions
are you asking how are you doing your
due diligence how do you trust your
instinct
that's most of it what i would say is
that
you know i left a long time ago so 20
something years ago and i had
14 15 years of investing in in hedge
funds
away from them and at times you know
your own
intuition takes you in a different
direction from what you imagine
you know david might want or yale might
do and
what i found from doing that time and
time again
was that they were right
it just takes a long time to internalize
lessons
i do have a few things that are
different than and again
there's been so much time since i was
there i'm sure they have evolved
in their thinking and sophistication in
many many ways it's far beyond
my time there but the one that's a big
difference for me that i never
quite uh embraced was so david was
always a die in the wool
value guy and if you read what he says
about you know where they invest in the
stock market they want small cap and
value
and we had those biases in our
portfolios before they were factors
as it goes back to the early 90s um
what i saw from investing since is there
are very few people
like the ill endowment that have a
capital structure that really can invest
for
you know decades if not longer most
people the long term is probably three
to five years
even private equity firms you see they
turn around their companies in three to
five years and in three to five years a
lot can happen
that is different from what might play
out over the long term
so in different areas you know the
easiest one to describe is a u.s
equity market yale's portfolios tended
to be very value biased and
my portfolios were much more balanced
because i just didn't think
that if you're value and wrong for 10
years that's actually not
okay when you have clients uh one of the
things andy golden at
princeton said in the podcast is
to finish first you first have to finish
and so that type of thing i tend to
prefer to have a little more balance in
my portfolio stylistically but
for the most part those are all on the
margin you know my investing
is primarily my comfort zone is
investing in managers
and then on the side i'll do things that
i think i can do which is usually
a more efficient way of investing in a
manager but that's really what i learned
and what i've continued to apply ever
since
yeah and what's so fascinating about
this i think that also these lessons
apply differently to different people
right one of the things that
is always debated is uh kind of
diversification can protect wealth
uh concentration usually builds it but
at the same time uh concentration can
also
mean that uh there's insolvency and so
there's always kind of the balance
of risk and reward how do you think
about uh for many of the people who are
coming to this from a more cryptocentric
uh viewpoint should we take some of the
timeless investing lessons and try to
apply it to what's you know forming as a
new asset class
or their kind of completely new rules as
i think maybe some people believe like
how do you just look at uh using the
experience and education
and frankly the well-worn path of
success
in investing for decades if not
centuries
and apply it to a new asset class so
like just what's the framework that you
use for that
yeah it's a it's a lot easier to
describe on the outside how i would view
it
than advice i would be able to give for
someone on the inside so let me start
with that i'm a big
fan of crypto have been for a few years
without really being in the weeds and
understanding it
for one part of a portfolio that's
incredibly important
which is asymmetric options
so in this case that asymmetric option
is the possibility i don't know if it's
true or not but the possibility then a
world of fiat money debasement
that bitcoin let's say let's start with
bitcoin
becomes a store of value that's a better
store of value than
capital market stocks bonds companies
gold
anything else um i say i don't know
because
it's totally unclear if that is sort of
we don't have a long enough history to
know if that
actually happens in the in that world um
so
you know for me and other institutions
you start with bitcoin you then go to
bitcoin and ethereum frankly that's
where i am today
and then you start to pay more attention
to the ecosystem and you could look at
d5 protocols and
and nfts and stuff like that and i think
you're starting to see it
from the institutional perspective it
all looks like a venture investment
so the first legs when when yale was in
the news for you know investing in
crypto a couple years ago well not
really they were just investing with
chris dixon at andreessen
and and that was another venture
investment and it fits right in you have
a venture portfolio that's what it looks
like
uh more recently there's been news that
that some of these institutions are
buying bitcoin maybe bitcoin ethereum
directly
but again it's far more of
a diversifying option to them so then
you turn it to your original question is
what does that mean if you're inside it
you are certainly according to that lens
in a seat where you are taking risk in
an attempt to build wealth
and there's downside to it uh but one of
the things you find you know a lot of
the smart people in this ecosystem are
younger
makes a ton of sense to have that kind
of experience in your career
where you're really trying to build
something and there's so much to do and
you put so much effort into it
is incredibly valuable no matter what
the outcome is
so a lot of what we talk about a big
section of the book when i talk about
decision making and investing is process
over outcome
and the corollary i would give i left
business school in 1999
and that was the peak of the internet
bubble um
there was one of all of my classmates
probably
half or more ran to do some internet
startup there was only
one that monetized it but i would argue
that
probably like 90 of the people that did
it
got experience that was so valuable for
them that it propelled them in different
ways through their career so
i wouldn't think about it so much from
that lens of is it binary
like am i going to get rich or not
usually the people that are in it to get
rich
may or may not have success but they
don't ultimately achieve
kind of their own satisfaction or call
it fulfillment
at the end of that road maybe they do if
they get really rich and then they can
go do the things they
that they really want to do but it
really is about
being involved in something exciting and
building something
and then learning along the way to
figure out you know each person's path
of where they want to end up
yeah before we go any further on the
investing side i would be
doing the audience a disservice if i
didn't uh talk to you about the uh the
media empire that you're building in
terms of uh
uh capital allocators podcast which is
fantastic uh and then you've got a new
book that's coming out
maybe let's just start with why spend so
much time uh
creating content and interviewing people
like what is the interest or the
intrigue
uh in doing that stuff on a daily basis
yeah
well it came out it didn't come out by
design so when i left protege a couple
years ago i was doing a couple projects
i had time on my hands i had written a
book
my first book which was really about
case studies for startup hedge funds
and i had done a few podcasts and it
kind of demystified it
so i just thought it would be fun to go
run around and talk to some of my
friends and share those conversations
i did not plan on having it be like a
media business i always view myself as
an investor it was just something to do
on the side
and and it stayed that way for a couple
years now one of the benefits
of that is after 20 something years in
the business i do have a lot of
relationships with really really
talented people that generally aren't
available in the public
and as the podcast grew
there was real benefit to those people
to tell their story so that was that was
fun
it's kind of i called it the business of
building goodwill on my personal balance
sheet
um and then only about a year and a half
ago
the the main project i was working on
ended and
around the same time advertisers started
calling on the podcast i said hi like
maybe this could be a business out of it
um and the content part of it
i've just enjoyed so what i describe
what i'm doing today is a little bit
different from what i had in the past
because a lot of my time is spent the
same way
i created a little vision statement
which is to
learn share and implement the
the process of elite investors through
compounding
knowledge and relationships and the
biggest difference in what i do today
from what i did back then was the word
share
so i naturally like sharing what i learn
with other people
and when you're managing a pool of
capital that's not
you know maybe it helps you on the
margin maybe you share and you get more
investors but the goal is
to compound capital and to grow your
business so to have the goal
being contributing to help other people
is just
innately satisfying for me and so it
started that way
it just started as i'm doing these
conversations hey the people i have on
the show are getting a lot out of it
that's great i wasn't asking anything in
return
still don't and then things come out of
it
which is you know it's almost like this
i don't know if you'd call it the gig
economy portfolio
but there's a whole bunch of different
things so you know there's the podcast
in the business around it
i get asked to do a lot of speaking
sometimes that's interviewing people so
they can tell their story sometimes it's
me telling my story um and then
you know call it advisory like i work
with a small number of
of managers mostly hedge funds still but
some allocators as well
with the goal of i just want to help
them make more money like it's fun
making money
um they want to make more money and
just from my experience there's just
lots of different ways i can help
what i don't do is sell for them or
market but there's a lot of strategy
there's a lot of understanding what
they're trying to do in their portfolio
and a lot of times these firms even if
they're successful they don't have
lots of adults in the room um i mean
they may have adults in the room but
they don't have adults that have
independent thought and experience and
so it's just really fun to be able to
help that way and
kind of all these things come together
and and what's happened over time is the
more
i built it up and i've hired a few
people to help it gives me more time to
think
about investing and to share those
thoughts and so you know we have a
little
premium content membership and more and
more i'm just
sharing more investment ideas with that
and i just like it it's
that's all there is to it i'm a middle
child so i don't mind the spotlight and
it's fun i love the viewpoint of it
uh what is the most memorable interview
you've ever done and not necessarily
because it's the most you know
well-known person or the most successful
but just is there one interview that you
look back you're like wow that one was
really special and sticks out
i can answer that in a lot of different
ways so let me give you two or three
stories the first is when i interviewed
scott malpass who's the retired cio at
notre dame
it was such a fantastic interview that
covered
so much about what he had done that i
came away saying
that is exactly what i'd hoped to do on
this podcast
um and that's resonated with lots of
people people really point to that
interview
and it was really i knew scott from when
i worked at yale
i hadn't seen him in many many years and
i was like hey what have you been doing
the last 15 or 20 years and he just did
a brilliant job of walking through it
including the subtleties of how they ran
that office and how they evolved
so that was one that was like right in
the sweet spot
the other ones that stand out to me are
when i learned something
way beyond what i could have imagined
and usually that comes from
these kind of interdisciplinary thought
leaders from outside of investing so
when i've had non-cios and non-managers
on
the lens i use is do i think i can talk
to someone who's going to share
something
that will help me be a better investor
help other cios be a better investor
and the the first of those was andy duke
so annie's done
a lot of stuff but the whole science of
decision making is i knew everything
about behavioral finance but none of
that was prescriptive
and annie's work is like how do you get
better at this
and so that was really fun i learned a
tremendous amount from her
and the other two of that ilk and really
the first i should say the first
section of the book i call a toolkit and
it's five tools
that these people that are cios they're
really disciplines that they need to
know
but it's not taught in investing
decision making is one of them another
one is negotiations
so i went to business school i got
taught negotiations i read all the books
you're supposed to
to work and i was terrible like every
negotiation i ever had in my career i
got crushed it didn't matter what it was
and then i met i got introduced to a guy
named dalian kane who's a professor at
yale
teaches negotiations and he has a way
that he's developed of of teaching
that's really
much more practical about how you go
about a negotiation
and it was the last face-to-face
interview i did uh
not i just did one face-to-face but
pre-covet and
i was just blown away by how much i
didn't know
about how you can actually effectuate a
negotiation in a way that felt good for
me and and learned a tremendous amount
from that and the last one i would say
is within the investment process
so i interviewed a cognitive
psychologist his name is gary klein
and gary invented the pre-mortem
analysis
originally for fighter pilots and it's a
it's a risk management tool that anytime
you're making a decision
any kind of decision pretty much when
you think you're at the answer
you conduct this little 20-minute
exercise that he describes on the
podcast and it allows you to do a whole
bunch of things it allows you
unearth other possibilities you might
not have thought of it's particularly
good in a
in the team setting it reduces your
confidence and we know that everybody
has overconfidence when you're going
into making decisions
and it was just prescriptive like i
listened to this and i went wow
i can't believe i didn't know this and i
can't imagine
all the decision process all the
investment committee meetings i ran with
our team
and how much we could have benefited
from having this little 15 or 20 minute
exercise at the end of that process so
those are three examples there are so
many i've done you know 200
episodes at this point in time yeah it's
crazy how
uh the actionable little things can have
the biggest impact right like
i think that that's probably one of the
things people don't understand
if they've never done kind of a high
volume of interviews is they expect the
big ideas to be the most impactful but
you kind of get desensitized a little
bit to the big ideas because you just
heard
them and what you find is most people
actually think pretty similarly whether
that's good or bad
it's more so just the like here's a
specific thing that i do in my life that
has had a positive impact and you can
take that away
those are usually the cool things um the
podcast isn't the only thing you do
you've got another book out
uh maybe talk a little bit just kind of
around what was the impetus for uh for
writing the book and then kind of what
was the process like
yeah well i started writing the book
because after a while of doing the
podcast just to what you just said
about all these little lessons i just
couldn't remember them anymore
and i thought at some point in time it'd
be great to just write them down write
write them down get those
like four or five nuggets from every
episode and just have them somewhere
uh but i didn't have time to do it and
then covet hit
and any travel i had was shut down and a
bunch of the things i was working on i
knew i was gonna have some more time so
i decided to just start writing it
uh and it really is an attempt to get at
exactly what you just said
so there is this section i mentioned
that are these these tools the first
section is a toolkit
so there's a chapter about interviewing
a chapter about decision making a
chapter about negotiations
leadership and management all super
important things for anyone
leading an investment organization but
none of which are taught
you know from the cfa or anything else
anyone in investing does
and then there's an investment section
which is sort of what did i
learn after dave swenson um
not did i what did i learn from people
how have these cios evolved taking that
yale model and what are they doing with
it
and then the last section which is
probably the most fun
uh is the the by virtue of what i said
starting to write the book came with
curating the best quotes
from what was 3 500 pages of transcripts
it ended up being i think 859
quotes i might have that number a little
bit wrong um you can't just put a book
together that's 859
quotes but it did allow me to figure out
what to write in those first two
sections and there were 160 phenomenal
quotes left over and i categorized them
and that best section that last section
is called nuggets of wisdom there's a
investment lesson section and a life
lesson section and they are
those great one-off nuggets um from all
those shows
i have to ask what what's your favorite
investing book is it swenson's book is
there another one
what would you categorize as the best
one or your favorite
i mean it's hard for me to get past
swenson's book
um because when i was reading it i
remember it vividly i knew what was
going to come on the next page like i
had lived that book
there are so many great ones i think my
most
recent favorite book is morgan housel's
psychology of money because it's the
lessons in it are very
straightforward but the storytelling and
the writing
is sort of consummate morgan it's just
brilliant
it's so easy to read and so much fun um
those are there are a lot i don't know
that my favorites would be all that much
different from other people's but
uh but those are two of them i love it
you you're
a very well read and very educated
in the business of investing but you
take a little bit different approach to
investing than most of the people have
on the podcast most people are
uh the managers they're the direct
allocators
uh you take much more of a kind of
limited partner seat so you're taking
capital you're giving that to these
managers
and i want to talk about the last 12
months from the lp viewpoint
uh it seems like uh as before we jumped
on here i told you we've lived 20 years
and 18 months
right so maybe just walk through from a
macro view like
what has changed and how do you sit in
the lpc
view the world today that might be
different than the world you know 12
months ago when uh the pandemic hit the
united states
yeah you know most of the perspective of
sitting in the lp seat
is is much longer term than changes over
even a year
but there are different points in time
where you see points of emphasis
shifting and certainly in the last 12
months
the two i guess you'd call them
megatrends maybe there's three one
that's continued
um were esg
and then through that diversity equity
and inclusion
and then going into this year and the
one that i would say
continues and for good reason is private
equity and we talk about each of those
the fourth though that is brand new and
is in the early innings
of serious institutional consideration
is crypto
and so um if you
if you look at the lens of each of those
esg is sort of fascinating in that it's
not new
people have talked about it for a long
time but starting when really starting
with
davos just before kovid and greta
thundberg
in in europe the year before davos last
year
every single conversation was about
climate change
and so who knows why it's a malcolm
gladwell tipping point
but for the first time particularly on
the environmental
side because governance was always
something considered important
people really started paying attention
and that is
uh that is a you know pardon the
expression
in light of what we're talking about but
that is a tsunami that
will not abate anytime soon so
there's a lot of implications for that
there's a lot of definitions that people
are working through
there's a whole question of like what
will what is good like what will
indexing being what's the right strategy
there's lots of things but
everyone in in that community is paying
attention to
what they own already as it relates to
environmental risk
and then how they want to tweak their
portfolios again not revolutionize their
portfolios but tweak their portfolios
um the s came out of it right so we had
george floyd
during the pandemic and all of a sudden
for the first time people
really thought seriously about diversity
i don't have to go on a big tangent
about that i did a mini-series and i
came away
thinking that this industry is the wrong
place to
pay a lot of it i don't say this
industry is the wrong place to make
meaningful change in a short period of
time
because we are the tail that wags the
dog and it really has to do with
talent and where that talent comes from
and how you groom it and if it doesn't
exist in the industry today you can't
just flip a switch and have it exist
tomorrow
so you know i've been telling people i
think the way to make that kind of
change happen in the industry is to
start with the winners start with the
large incumbents the large asset
managers
and force them to have more diverse
hiring practices because typically when
a new fund spins out
there's already a brand attached to them
and if you want
a new great organization that is
diversely run in the future they have to
come out of a place
that they have that brand because it's
just too hard to do a startup anyway
um and so that's you know the governance
stuff let's let's
let's watch so one of the australian
super funds recently completely divested
from china
for governance reasons hasn't really hit
the news that much
but that'll be interesting to see so
that's the esg and diversity
private equity we know about there's a
lot of structural reasons why that bid
will remain strong and now we've got
spax on top of that and that'll just
keep going
and crypto is fascinating right the the
the case for crypto
from an institutional lens today
is no different than it was than what it
was in 2017.
so it really starts with this store of
value monetary debasement
and bitcoin and what that might mean and
then you get into an ecosystem
from there most of the institutions
don't yet
understand more deeply everything that's
happening underneath
they do understand that there's been a
lot of talent and a lot of resources
attracted to it that are building things
on the blockchain
and there are some applications that
might make sense in the future so it
looks like a venture investment to them
but to give you an example a couple of
months ago i got
asked if i could help put together a
discussion with michael saylor from
microstrategy
just to hear his case on bitcoin and
this was last fall and i said no
you know the people i know really aren't
that interested same person asked me
again
uh in about a month ago and i said yep
we can and i asked
30 we you know we together we asked
about 30 cios
every single one either participated or
said oh my gosh i can't make it let me
send my number two
so they are learning and taking it
seriously and there will be a lot of
capital that follows that down the road
yeah what's so fascinating to me i think
about uh let's take sailor as an example
i've gotten to know him
uh pretty well and what he's doing is
not really that complicated right
he has a belief now whether he's right
or wrong the market will determine
but he's basically got a belief that uh
he is able to get access to capital
markets where there is a
devaluing currency he's going to take
that currency and then he's going to
convert it to something that he thinks
will
continue to appreciate in purchasing
power over time and so
it's as classic of a of an arbitrage as
there ever is right is you're going to
give me basically free money i'm going
to go buy something that i think goes up
200 a year
uh that sounds like a pretty you know
easy investing strategy and if you
believe that that's true then you should
go participate
but i think that the the crazier part
about the whole thing
is one he's doing it with large dollars
obviously right and so that kind of
catches people's attention
but two is the people who are giving him
the money but i think to me that's the
part when he you know he puts out these
like convertible
uh bonds and stuff when you start to
look at uh and try to peel away and see
like who's actually giving him a billion
dollars at zero percent interest
it's not you know me right it's not a
bunch of crypto
you know or bitcoin kind of ludics who
who basically say hey this thing is
going to be you know the global reserve
currency
we're talking about the largest
financial institutions on wall street
we're talking about cios like we're
talking about you know more your world
than my world
and that to me is the fascinating part
of this is uh
don't listen to what people say just
watch what they do with their dollars
almost right
yeah you know i can't say specifically i
know who's doing that but but i do
think that there are rational reasons on
the other side that might seem crazy
when you just say it that way
um so a lot of that goes to
thinking about what some of these pools
of capital are trying to achieve
so let's just take a pension fund you
know i've had ash williams who runs
state florida pension board and and
chris haleman from calstrs on
on the show they're trying to fund
future retirees income
that does not require 200 returns uh
they have a liability stream they had to
figure out how to meet a liability
stream
now if they're lending at zero they're
not going to do that but
there are a lot of insurance companies
there's a lot of pension funds
that that an investment like that
might meet their objectives you know
within the portfolio of what they're
doing
and so they're not not everyone out
there is trying to make the most money
they can
all the time they're really trying to
say what's this money for
you know what what's the purpose of this
money and how are we going to structure
our assets so that we
maximize the probability of fulfilling
that purpose and you know i don't know
the specifics of like the microstrategy
convert
and it rates you know who's lending to
the u.s government at zero
it doesn't make any sense to me but
there are people who i think
think very very carefully about it and
it may well fit into the structure of
their assets
let's go a little further on this in
terms of you talk to cios
um at pensions endowments foundations
kind of really all across the uh the
investment spectrum
what are they saying about crypto right
now so there's obviously an interest
rate you kind of
uh alluded to that but just are they
thinking of this as let me go put you
know 25 basis points in my portfolio and
cross my fingers because i think i
bought a lottery ticket is it something
that's more pervasive than that
just what are you hearing yeah so the
case right now and i i
think we just talked about this i'm i
was curious to hear what they're hearing
too and so i did almost like a i don't
even want to say crypto 101 it's
probably like a crypto001 miniseries
that's coming out
maybe out you know by the time we do
this um there's really only two cases
that i see
in that world for now um one is the
monetary
fiat money debasement and saying that
crypto
is a better way to diversify against
portfolio risk assets than other things
um and the other is is from a venture
capital lens which is this is an
ecosystem that is still in the very
early innings
that will have or may have tremendous
value
accreting from every piece of the
activity so then you can set aside
the store of value coins and instead
you're now you're getting into protocols
and
and assets and all the things that will
happen off the blockchain
um the way that they tend to participate
in that again
going all the way back to what we're
talking about with dave swenson which is
you know how do you own a piece of that
ecosystem um
it's not quite equity yet it might be
tokens they're not going to do that
directly
but they might do it through a venture
capitalist they might do it through a
public markets manager
and that's how they're participating in
a very small way
because what they're starting to wake up
and pay attention to is that this isn't
going away
that there's real technology here that
may well change uh a lot of business
you know somewhere down the road now
what i would tell you is
that concept is not new to any of these
people um
when i was talking to venture
capitalists in the early 90s
every year there was something that was
new and exciting and it wasn't as
pervasive as say blockchain technology
but
it was you know palm computing
and there was these pen-based things way
before we had iphones
and some of those were way too early and
it didn't work and there was oh there's
always some innovative technology that
they're on the forefront of and clearly
this ecosystem is it today in the same
way the internet probably was
20 years ago um and i think it takes
time
for institutions to embrace any new area
it usually starts with a thought leader
like a yale or somebody like that
first saying hey they're interested and
that we've seen those
and then having a run so if you think
about 2017
uh it's some institutions were in the
news for really investing in some
venture funds that were in the ecosystem
but then
then the price of bitcoin collapsed and
now you have another rise in bitcoin and
so people start to pay attention to it
they say hey
what happened over the last couple of
years what's been developed
it feels like the floor is higher than
it was we now have proof that even
though there was this 80
selloff we've made all the money back
and then some
maybe now is another time to participate
so you need both
the thought leader to move and then
proof of concept in the markets
that this is a place you can make money
and and that there's
real innovation happening underneath so
all of that is happening you know better
than that ecosystem that it's happening
uh but they're learning about it and i
think
that's where the real capital will come
into the space
yeah what's fascinating to me is uh of
course you get kind of the innovative
forward-thinking folks to uh to jump in
first um
in 2018 uh the first two u.s public
pension funds uh
invested very similar type of fund right
venture capital for 80 20
basically uh give or take went into
bitcoin
uh good market timing it's up a lot
right
all of that but uh what has been
surprising is that
everyone always talks about kind of
breaking the seal right the first one or
the second one that goes and then hey
you get all the fast followers
i don't i'm not aware of another public
pension fund that's decided to do that
yet
and so it's uh it's one of these things
where i always go back to the bill gates
quote of like we overestimate what's
possible in one year but underestimating
10.
and you know now we're sitting kind of
two three years in and uh if you look at
various aspects of the uh institutional
world
public pension funds probably way behind
where i thought they would have been
given that development in 2018.
corporate uh treasuries way ahead of
where you would have thought they would
be right in terms of now you got fortune
500 companies and and
you know maybe there's more maybe
there's not but but you're starting to
see that conversation change
i think the key piece to this whole
thing though is the world that you live
in terms of these large
kind of multi-billion dollar uh you know
cios
sitting and saying look this isn't the
lottery ticket right this is a core part
of our of our strategy and maybe that's
only you know 200 basis points right
but we're going to go and we're going to
invest in this ecosystem and it's not
just through one single manager we're
actually going to build a portfolio of
managers we're going to have
liquid and we're going to have private
and really kind of all of those
you know timeless examples of what
swenson and yale have done for so many
years
uh kind of on a macro basis across
traditional assets it feels like that's
gonna get all rebuilt whether it's
coexistence or replacement in the crypto
world
and so somebody's gonna figure out you
know what is the portfolio construction
look like for this new world and my
guess is that it actually looks a lot
like the old world just
you know new technology right yeah well
i think that's just right
and the way it happens uh
you can almost follow it through the the
adoption of other colored asset classes
over time right
so public pensions you know pension
funds they will not be the first movers
and the reason has nothing to do with
who the cio is and what they think
it's the governance structure on top of
them so if you have a board that's
you know firemen and policemen and good
luck
trying to you know they they're not
gonna know it's very hard for them
to adopt something new you know without
proof of concept
and that usually starts for them with a
consultant and the consultant
isn't in a risk-taking business so
they're not gonna they're not gonna
promote
a new ecosystem like that until they see
it in the hands of other people
so what typically happens is you see it
with individuals which which
is where the ecosystem is today and then
as they have success you see it in
family offices
the family offices or the leaders of
those families might sit on the boards
of endowments and foundations
and then they bring into the boardroom
and acceptance that allows
those first movers to move forward and
there's just much less governance
constraints on them
and and from there you tend to get to
you know more public pension or
sovereign wealth corporates are
interesting
because this is a different dynamic
where you're seeing it on corporate
balance sheets themselves
not in the corporate pension fund
necessarily so the usually the corporate
pension fund is slow moving as well
but they what we've seen already at
these leading mover
really technology-minded ceos putting
bitcoin on their balance sheet in
particular
uh is a new thing and i think that
there's a lot of capital
uh that's going to be coming behind it
yeah when
you kind of just zoom out so crypto's
one part of the world but obviously you
look at kind of
all asset classes uh over the last 12
months what's been the biggest surprise
and it's
somewhat of a loaded question just
because there were so many surprises uh
everything from the public health crisis
to kind of the fed and central banks
from the world's response and
and the way that different asset classes
responded to that but
is there one event or one specific asset
that you're like this was the
really big shocking moment to you
you know i still scratch my head it's
easy to see in retrospect
i i still scratch my head on what
happened with the equity markets
um you know that we sit today with an
economy that probably will
on a percentage basis we'll do a lot
better than it did last year but stock
markets are higher and
on a nominal basis is a lot lower it
does make sense like i understand why it
happens
with fed pumping money in but there have
been a lot of those dynamics
so you have you have that in the u.s you
have you know people were thinking there
was going to be a wave of defaults
so all these distressed debt investors
and high-yield people were just licking
their chops saying you know
this is going to be great and that money
just saves all these companies
and then of course you can anticipate
that crypto is going to be worth a lot
more at some point in the future
but there's not that many like i
rebought my
i bought and sold kind of my core
holding in bitcoin ethereum a couple
times and i rebought it last august
thank goodness um but i've i've never
owned anything that went up
you know 5x in three or four months and
and
those trees don't grow to the sky
linearly and so
you know we'll see what happens from
here but i i think those are all
huge huge surprises i
i tend to think that uh that is not
going to be the top of this cycle where
it goes nobody knows
but uh you you're going to be saying
some crazy thing like you know i can't
believe i owned an asset that did x in
in 12 months or whatever it ends up
being but uh it just feels like
and part of this too also is like i
think a lot about uh
the way that folks evaluate uh
traditional assets and asset classes
uh is pretty well understood right i
mean literally you know swenson wrote
the book in 2000 and uh
it served as a fantastic manual as you
described it
uh for large asset allocators uh
literally for two decades
um and so when you start to look at
today's world there's kind of two
schools of thought right
one is uh hey everything's overvalued
and
i can describe why but uh it's unlikely
to stay like this forever
uh and then there's this new school of
thought and i put new because we have
yet to figure out whether they're
correct or not
is uh no we're talking about using old
valuation models for more capital
intensive businesses trying to apply it
to
you know kind of capital light
software-type businesses or these assets
like
uh bitcoin and other cryptocurrencies or
digital assets they just don't fit into
those old models
less about like which valuation
methodology is correct
and more of just like how do you try to
understand both of them right like you
come from a classically trained
valuation kind of methodology and world
but you're also very open-minded and
forward-thinking i think when it comes
to cryptocurrencies in blockchain so
like how do you
try to uh reduce as much cognitive
dissonance there as possible
it's really hard that's actually the
best answer that might be the best
answer
it's really hard right you're absolutely
right i was brought up in the business
understanding cash flow business
valuation
and you know in 2017 when i first
started learning about crypto i should
say
uh my old chief technology officer
protege partners gave us a luncheon chat
and it had to be in 2011 or 12
about bitcoin he's russian he would say
bitcoin you know we'd go through this
whole thing and
i you know i was just like what are you
talking about this is ridiculous you
know
so i didn't get it um i
i think that um one of the things i've
learned
through my career and it really came
from a line
that the late peter bernstein said over
and over about risk
and he would say risk means you don't
know what will happen
um and the the corollary the add-on to
that was even if you think you do
um so i always and and maybe it's just
me
like i worked with dave swenson dave is
right like a lot and he sees the world
in black and white and he's deeply
convicted in what he does and i never
felt i had the kind of conviction that
he did
um so i do understand cash flow
investing much more in 2017 i was like
well
what are these things going to turn into
because you have to keep in mind
i lived through 99 in 2000 right i had
friends
built brilliant people building
businesses on the internet that made no
sense to me
made no sense at all and most of those
it turned out
didn't didn't survive and so i do have
this baggage if you want to call it that
or this
belief that i've seen through my career
that ultimately
things have to turn into profitable
ventures for them to sustain themselves
but then you get lucky if you're me you
have a podcast with someone like chris
dixon
and chris described for me he just does
a wonderful job of of
these analogies to help you bridge that
information gap so one of them was i was
asking about just this whole token
ecosystem of like you know
i don't get it and he said well the best
performing asset
in anywhere in the world over the last
20 something years
were domain names you could have bought
pizza.com
for like 30 and 20 years later someone
sold it for 20 million dollars
and the reason was obviously it was a
scarce asset
that particular domain in an ecosystem
the internet that got used
far more than anyone anticipated and so
that was an analogy i completely
understood
and i still will look with skepticism
and say will any one of these protocols
be that in the future where people use
it so much
that the tokens become true i'm looking
at what's going on with nba top shot
and i reached out to a friend and said
you need to explain to me
i went on the website and i saw the zion
williamson clip
of him swatting away the shot and
someone's trying to sell that clip
that i just saw for 250 thousand dollars
and we went through this with ari paul
and we went through this whole
conversation of like
what is art you know what's the
difference between a picasso and a
forgery of a picasso
and a chanel bag or a birken bag
and and something that looks exactly
like it might have even been made in the
same manufacturing facility and so
you do get these analogs that hold in
the virtual
you know in in the in the actual world
um but i do at my core
still understand the nature of cash
flows and how that
turns into business value more than
other things so that is kind of crypto
versus the traditional world the
the change in profit margins of these
technology companies the dominance of
the large ones
is so much different that i do think
there's some valuation premium
that said i have an analog with japan so
early in my career
the japanese equity market traded at 100
times earnings and people thought that
was just
what it did right it was different it
just that's how expensive it traded
and at some point in time you know late
90s and on it collapsed
so it's not so much
that it's binary uh and i just wrote a
piece last week for
my premium subscriptions it's called i
told you so there's a little brief blog
type piece
that would point you to there there
there are voices now
calling for doomsday jeremy grantham and
you know value equities and jeffrey
gundlach with uh
high yield defaults and even mark cuban
saying bitcoin is in a big bubble
um what i learned over my career is that
uh you don't they will be right
someone will be right and they will say
i told you so but you'll never
understand how long did it take them to
get there what was the opportunity cost
and how many other people were wrong
along the way
and i started paying attention to this
back in 2007 2008 because we were
investors with john paulson in his
subprime short and it was the perfect
investment
the greatest trade ever according to
greg zuckerman who wrote the book about
him
and i started paying attention to all
these people calling out
these things over the years and what you
find is that there are many many more
people calling for a crisis
than actually predict the crisis so you
know i i think you just look at all of
it with this deep humility that
you can't really know um and my whole
career has been betting on and following
people
so the most compelling thing to me about
the crypto world
is the knowledge that the people in the
valley
the jurisdictions of the world tell me
that you know
look this is where the top programmers
are going
and when they go there they're going to
build stuff that has value in the future
and that i buy into whole-heartedly yeah
it's basically the argument of the
intellectual capital flowing more so
than the financial capital right
financial capital goes all over the
place it does crazy things but
hopefully markets are somewhat efficient
and kind of get them back in line but
uh the intellectual capital definitely
is kind of a leading indicator and i you
know i've even been surprised one of the
the uh craziest yet uh you know most
uh sensical uh ways to invest in the
space is i've seen people who literally
go and they say look all of the
information's on chain
and so why don't we go and we look at
actual the developer activity in some of
these ecosystems and so we can literally
see
where is the most code being contributed
right now like let's go look there
and uh it reminds me a lot of like what
did hedge funds do i mean
you got a front row seat this is taking
pictures of cars at walmart right there
you know the oil tanks how high are they
like all that kind of stuff
and so it's just people are constantly
going to look for an edge and look for
data and information and i think that uh
in this kind of digital world where
there's a lot more transparency
uh you know one of the issues could be
there's more noise than signal but if
you can find those signals then it can
lead to quite profitable
investing strategies yeah yeah couldn't
agree more
all right uh before we wrap up i want to
ask you three questions ask everybody
and you'll get to ask me one to finish
uh the first is what is the most
important book that you've read i know i
asked you earlier what's your favorite
investing book but what is the most
important book
a book that you read and it just had a
massive impact on your life
um so this one
may not be great for your audience but
it will at some point in time so a
friend of mine
introduced me a number of years ago to
the a book called finding meaning in the
second half of life
okay um
and it uh
i just turned 50 so i guess i'm almost
at the second half of my life
but it had less to do with that and more
to do with sort of
always the answer to some questions of
like what do you know today that you
wish you knew 10 years ago
and it was the first time i read
something that i said oh wow i like
actually might be able to learn this
before i have to learn it and wish i
knew it from experience
but it's a beautiful book uh there are a
lot of them
uh but that that is one in the last
couple years that stands out
yeah that's a great book i feel like
everyone even if you're younger could uh
go read that and probably
take away a ton of stuff from that so
that's a fantastic suggestion
uh second question is a little bit more
personal it comes from our friends over
at eight sleep
uh i used to sleep like five or six
hours was horrendous almost wore it as a
badge of pride
and then my wife was like hey knock it
off you know you probably should sleep a
little bit more and so
uh mateo who's the ceo there uh helped
me out with this eight sleep and i
started sleeping on this thing
and you can basically make it freezing
cold and all of a sudden now i'm like
a convert of the sleep religion right
i'm like if i don't get my eight hours
i'm
uh very aware that i didn't get the
eight hours so what is your sleep
schedule and kind of how has that
changed over the years
yeah um so i'm a big proponent of sleep
i am i've been i i've had a fitbit for a
number of years at this point i only use
it to track my sleep it's not even that
good at that
um so i
like to try to get for me it's about
seven hours if i can get it
um and most of the time i do
but you know for example recently i
haven't been and it just
you know it just happens you're more
aware of it and for sure
like i get cranky if i don't sleep a lot
and things like that so
i've always been a big proponent of
sleep i i view myself as an eight-hour
night guy i just haven't quite gotten
there
the biggest change for me with kovid and
you know a little bit before
so i used to commute from connecticut
into the city and that's an
hour commute each way and when you try
to fit in that plus a workday
plus working out sleep easily can get
compromised
and combination of covet and
what i've been doing which doesn't
really require me to certainly not to go
in every day but not even that much
uh it's been monumentally better in
making it
more reasonable for me to get called a
full night's sleep
yeah it uh feels like covid was a very
big inflection point for people
and everyone started to ask themselves
not only hey why do i live in this city
uh if i don't have to go into an office
but also you know what i what do i do
all day
and uh there's positive event negatives
one of the ones that i think people
in new york and in the city uh that was
a negative impact was
you don't realize how much you walk in a
day right even even just walking from
the train to
an office then you walk to lunch like
whatever like you end up doing a lot
more walking than i think people realize
if you sit at home then you know all
those steps go away so it's pretty crazy
uh last question for you is a fun one
aliens are you a believer or a
non-believer
boy oh boy i so i'm a believer that
there's a lot out there that i don't
understand but i'm not
sure aliens is one of them okay
when you say a lot of stuff out there
like other planets
stars and any ideas as to what it could
be other than
intelligent life um so i i don't really
specifically have any
information insight or opinions about
intelligent life elsewhere
but what i will say is i've had a number
of experiences in my life
and call them spiritual experiences not
not religious but spiritual
where um the power of intention
whether whether it's that or um
experiencing things that just didn't
make sense any other way came so let me
give you one example just specifically
a number of years ago i got taken to uh
it was at a little church it was one of
these guys who's
who like you know goes around and
predicts things and people bring
pictures of people who had passed away
and he's like talking to the dead and i
was just like come on
i didn't believe in any of it and i'm
sitting there
and he's going around and every single
conversation was
um you know oh you know they're thinking
of you it was about the last day
and i'm just like none of this applies
to me and so
it was early on in my protege years
things were going really really well
and i remember thinking to myself if
this guy i'd love to know that there's
like something else out there and if
this guy comes to me
wouldn't it be fun if there was some
sign that somehow like this guy would
say something completely different to me
than everybody else
like well you just thought it to myself
sure enough the guy came around and he
said
there's a bunch of family around you
not fam close to family they're all
telling you
you're on the right path keep doing what
you're doing and i went what
now it turned out as he said that i had
this like little flash
of um an aunt and uncle of mine who had
passed away probably two years before
that i hadn't hadn't even been thinking
about
and it was the first time i went okay
like that guy couldn't have made that up
and there probably is something else out
there and that you know gave me a lot of
comfort with like thinking about death
and all those kinds of things but
you know whether he was an alien or not
i can't really answer
i but here's the thing that i think is
is really crazy right is um
in those situations i always ask and i
don't have an answer more so than
anybody else but it's just like
how much of it is uh psychology and
biology at work
right versus like this like spiritual
thing and um
what it really tells me is like our
minds are things that we don't
understand forget intelligent life
elsewhere
like we don't understand our own oceans
but we don't understand our own brain
and the power of it and kind of just the
the idea that um it's something simple
hey if you sit down at a chair and you
have to think versus if you get up and
you walk around
scientifically it's better for your
brain to walk than to sit
right and you start to like understand
some of the stuff and you just realize
like we are
really really complex creatures so it's
cool to see those experiences as kind of
reminders of like
you know we're not geniuses right yeah
well if if you find the pill that
bradley cooper ingested in the movie
limit list let me know i'm up for trying
that one
ted i think that that is called adderall
uh you could ask me one question to uh
to finish up what uh one question you
have for me
what what
is the most surprising thing you've
learned
from doing a podcast about yourself
about myself um
there's a lot of things i would say
one the more structure i try to put
around the conversation the less
enjoyable and less learning i get
so i now almost do no prep i talk to the
guests you know four or five minutes
beforehand
uh and that's kind of a much more
enjoyable experience which ends up
making the content better
uh the second is asking really
good questions uh is hard and
usually it comes down to you got to be a
good listener to ask good questions
right and so kind of just the classic
like uh are you listening or are you
waiting to talk
uh type framework and then the third
thing i think
is uh it's the ultimate life lesson
right
it really is uh if you can make this
valuable for the audience if you can
make it valuable for the guest it ends
up being way more valuable for yourself
and not in kind of a selfish way but
it's just
you begin to learn that um
what you extract is is very kind of
zero-sum but when you give it's very
positive some right and i think that
that
uh lesson although it's in kind of a
non-financial
situation you mentioned earlier kind of
a personal balance sheet
right or kind of this idea of there's
non-economic
um you know pluses and minuses on a uh
on kind of uh
there are debits and credits if you will
and like to me that ends up changing the
way you think of interactions it ends up
changing the way you think of
conversations
and when you can make it win-win-win for
the audience the guest and yourself i
think that's
ultimately where like the real magic is
uh and early on like
yeah jim o'shaughnessy was one of the
first three people i ever interviewed
and he came in and you know what we did
the whole time he kept saying i don't
know and we laughed the whole time
and it was a blast and then i remember
saying to him afterwards like hey man i
sound like we got to do like more
structured stuff
and going back and thinking about it
it's like no that it that was the you
know one of the best interviews because
it was
fun we enjoyed it and he was being
honest and so it's just like how do you
kind of recreate that type of magic over
and over again
i can't do it every time but i think you
know this conversation was a great one
and
that's what i tried to do yeah pump i
think you're crushing that so
keep on keeping on with it i'm just
trying to keep up with you you every
time i turn around you're releasing uh
you really said you got books you got
all this stuff so one day i will be like
you when i grow up
ted listen where can we send people to
find you uh on the internet and then
find
the book or the podcast yeah thanks uh
so i have everything on
a website capitalallocatorspodcast.com
or capitalallocators.com
uh i'm on linkedin and a little bit on
twitter not as prolific as uh as you are
um but that's kind of where i put all
the content up and then
you know from the website people can
sign up for a mailing list i send out
once a month
and then we also have a you know some
premium content on top of that so
that's kind of where everything's housed
and uh welcome everyone to jump in
i'm a big fan so uh people should
definitely go check it out and we'll
have to do this again
uh in the future yeah i'm looking
forward to reversing the mic
on this one